hi guys my name is Tamra chambers and
this is Tamra's never seen I am back to
my old couch I decided that the new
office is a little cramped so this is
the new new location for Tamra's never
seen there's also some lovely
construction noises going on outside so
this is gonna be really fun really great
today I'm watching Terminator 2 I did
Terminator 1 with my little brother and
we filmed an entire 15-minute segment
and I didn't push record I tried to like
slice it up and edit it together as best
I could but it came out a little jumbled
but I am very excited to tackle this one
so let's get started Oh cameras never
seen ok initial response is that I liked
to better though I liked Arnold as the
bad guy more it's a little conflicting
but hey that's what I thought
I thought he was so intimidating and so
cold face as this bad guy and he was
cool is the good guy but I prefer as the
villain though the practical effects in
this were so incredible and after you
see like a terrible Mike Myers face mask
in that first one going up to these ones
and seeing like the practical effects of
like the metal splitting from the bad
guy and like it just it's so impressive
really cool still holds up incredibly
well so the movie opens up on this new
future and there's explosions and
new-and-improved bad guys and a burning
playground and it's all very intense and
you see Arnold come in and his weird
energy bolts teleportation this scene
where he steals clothes and the
motorcycle is way better than the first
movies scene where he steals it from the
Switchblade guys so much better he walks
into this super tough motorcycle bar and
he takes the clothes and motorcycle from
a super tough dude and
and then he go down to leave and the bar
owner comes out with a gun he's like I
just can't I can't allow you to take
these six they're not yours you gotta
give him back buddy Arnold walks over to
him just grabs the gun at him it's like
I don't care at all I don't even care a
little bit he takes his sunglasses from
him and it's so disrespectful in a
hilarious way I love that scene so much
he's so badass then you see the bad guy
who's dressed up like a cop and I had
this movie ruined for me because I
didn't watch it until 2016 but I already
knew the Honorable was the good guy the
second one and that this police guy was
the bad guy Doug and I were talking
about how cool it was to see it in
theaters when you didn't know the twist
and you were expecting him to still be
the Terminator this bad person and I
didn't even think about that until I was
talking with Doug about it but you see
the new bad guy and he's trying to find
John as a kid let me see John who is
angsty AF you guys so angsty also he
looks like he's ten I don't know did
they say he's an age at any point and
he's driving around on a little
motorcycle and stealing money out of an
ATM and he's just he hangs out with the
ginger who has a mullet I love it I love
everything about his character
John's foster dad comes out he's like
you get back in here and listen to your
mother
and John turns around he goes she's not
my mother Todd and Taj the worst comes
to worst I was the worst
I guess sitting right here
and he agrees hot is the worst you don't
like Authority do you so then you see
Sarah and she's in this insane asylum
and it's the worst like most TV insane
asylums are also just insane asylums in
general I assume ur awful they did it
there's one part in the insane asylum
where she's forced to take this sleeping
pill and or just like a calm down drug
and she has this Kyle flashback scene
where she sees Kyle and he's telling her
that she needs to go and help John
because now he's exposed since she's in
there and she's like I know I'm trying
so hard and then he leaves and she's
chasing around Kyle and dream Kyle and
it's just it's so sad and so far up the
whole story for Sarah is so fun to be
actual the bob because nah it's
suspenseful she's just this normal girl
who's just hanging out when all of a
sudden this crazy person comes and tells
her that she's like gonna have this son
who leads the resistance for the future
and that this Terminator is after her
and then she falls in love with this guy
they have sex have a child and then he
dies raise this child who's like the key
of all of humanity she gets thrown into
an insane asylum because she's crazy
her son doesn't even believe hers these
weird guards in the insane asylum who
like lick her face and it's just all
it's all very uncomfortable and I feel
so bad for her and it never really gets
emotionally resolved for her I feel like
I know that things get better and like
she ends up doing what she needs to and
saving everything and she develops a
better relationship with John but
emotionally speaking I feel like it
doesn't get resolved very well for Sarah
Connor
but just as Arnold was super badass in
this she is so badass in this there's
the scene where she's yelling at the
people in the insane asylum about how
it's all a dream where you're all living
in a what'd she say yeah you're all
living in a dream and and this guy and
him and him you're already right also
John is super badass which is cool to
have like a kid
representing kids
this movie is pretty neat then you meet
mr. Dyson who is this brilliant
brilliant man who is in charge of
creating Skynet and what ruins the world
in the future he doesn't know it he's a
great guy
super cute family so jump back to Arnold
trying to find John before the bad guy
finds John and he's riding around on his
motorcycle and he looks over John is
right there it's like well well that was
easy
so John and his mullet friend are in
this arcade and the bad guy and Arnold
are looking for him in there and they're
they like go out of the arcade into this
mall and then there's the awesome
hallway scene between Arnold bad guy and
John's
such a cool scene it's the first thing
you see like the metal how he like
reacts and how he liked forms back after
he's healed it's really cool and they're
in the middle of fighting over John and
there's just one one moment that struck
me is so funny I don't know if it was
Arnold or a stuntman there's this part
where the bad police guy throws them
both through this wall and they're
fighting they're fighting in the
fighting and Arnold or a stunt guy does
this hilarious stage-dive like I didn't
even learn how to do these kind of
things in like theatre school um so
they're throwing him that he's throwing
him through the wall and Arnold just
goes oh I'm going to then whoa like
really like all of his whole body just
goes stiff and like straight so he
doesn't hurt himself so bah bah bah this
is really funny so then John puts
together that he's a terminator but he's
here to help him and he's like I gotta
call my step parents they're the worst
Todd but I got to tell them so they
don't die that's the awesome scene where
the bad police guy took the shape of the
mom Jenelle and when they figure out
that it's not Jenelle there's this
awesome shot that they go back to where
she has or he I guess the bad guy has a
like a sword hand through a milk carton
and through the stepdads
head and it's just so cool and I really
really want to cosplay as the bad guy
police guy who is in the form of the mom
Jenelle with a sword hand I think I'd be
so cool has anyone ever done that can
you show it to me please God dang that'd
be awesome
and then he kills max their dog
No then it cuts back to Arnold and John
and Arnold hangs up the phone and goes
your step patterns on dead the end of a
conversation I know he didn't like them
very much but still abrupt then there's
the awesome escape scene from the insane
asylum and she's already escaping with a
little like paperclip but she got she
beats the crap out of those assholes so
we're mistreating her then Arnold and
John show up to help her and it's
perfectly timed and really cool is that
come with me if you want to live then
the bad policeman has claw hands and
he's getting onto their car and it's
just really good and intense and he so
in some respects Sarah Connor is a very
good mother she's teaching him how to
fight and be tough and learning the
tricks of the trade and in some respects
she's a terrible mother she's like why
did you save me you shouldn't have come
and saying but mom he starts crying and
the terminators like what's wrong with
your face why do you cry just no one
understands emotion in this movie and
it's a little she goes to kill mr. Dyson
who she knows is the person who has the
chip and is going to make all of this
terrible Judgment Day crap a reality but
she gets there she can't do it because
he's got a gorgeous family and he seems
like such a nice guy and then Arnold and
John show up and they're like no no do
it and then her and John hug and just
like I always loved you it's like well
that's nice
he's like ten you should have stolen
this before but okay good better better
life in memory so they convinced mr.
Dyson to not make the computer that will
destroy the world they go and it's
basically just one long final scene that
is so intense and so badass so they're
there and the police show up because
they shouldn't be in that building
destroying shit mr. Dyson dies and he
dies like holding this bomb above this
little the little you know what I'm
talking about don't you yes right good
words and so like the place explodes and
then the bad policeman guy shows up and
he like jumps into this police
helicopter and he like throws them out
and that's awesome and the helicopter
crashes into this frozen nitrogen
liquid nitrogen stuff but he's like
trying to get to them and then he
freezes cuz he's metal and then he
starts to crack apart and the cool hasta
LaVista baby scene is so flippin ah so
then he's near fire so he like melts and
goes back together and there's this
weird part that I don't really
understand the corner Sarah and he's
like called John she's like no never the
call to John he starts like hurting her
I said you can morph your whole body and
your voice to sound like people why
don't you just call to John there a
reason for that I don't know help
someone help then they start shooting at
the bad guy and Arnold finishes it off
and he shoots him and then he goes into
the lava flames and he's done then
Arnold decides that the only way to get
truly rid of all of the technology is if
he jumps in the fire lava - John is
really sad because he's like this
awesome father figure to him and he's
like I or you got to go and then he lets
him because he knows that he has to so
he goes down on this chain it's really
epic then he like starts morphing into
all of the people that he's ever like
pretended to be and that's super cool
and then she dies like he goes down a
bit to the lava with this fingers like
this is hilarious and dignified it's so
good
Arnold Schwarzenegger has never made me
feel things guys it was really good I
liked it
anyways that is the movie I really
enjoyed it I won't be watching three I
don't think for this everyone says to go
ahead and skip over that one but next
week I am doing a movie that I think a
lot of people are going to be every week
they are I don't know why this is news
to me but everyone's gonna be so upset
that I haven't seen this movie it's like
the first blockbuster ever I'm gonna
help show them what it's gonna be I
Danah dananananana dananananana does
also yesterday I posted on my personal
channel a video of miss Rachel tape deny
discussing what it's like to be an
industry kind of what she's been up to
and what her plans are and just catching
up with her which was really really nice
I love her and then one final thing I
wanted to say um making this video was a
little difficult as the last couple days
have been difficult specifically if you
live in America and I just wanted to
extend love to everyone specifically to
people who feel like they need a little
extra
um
yeah
so I'm yeah
[Music]